an outbreak of violence between Israel
and the Palestinian militant group Hamas
appeared to pause this morning after
every heavy exchanges of fire overnight
Israel launched a series of air strikes
in Gaza Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu said Israel is retaliating for
a Hamas rocket attack that hit a home
north of Tel Aviv yesterday Seth Doane
is in the Israeli city of said Road near
the border with Gaza that has been under
fire from Gaza Seth good morning good
morning we are inside an Israeli home
that was hit by one of the more than 60
rockets fired by Palestinians they've
already started to clean up but you can
see where that rocket tore through the
roof and hit the floor below me here
this is part of the latest escalation in
violence which was triggered when that
surprise attack injured seven people in
central Israel Israelis have fired back
huge orange fireball slit up the Gaza
City skyline overnight as warplanes
pounded targets in the Palestinian
territory on the ground in Gaza
buildings shops and military sites were
destroyed the militant group Hamas which
controls Gaza has been under pressure
locally due to an Israeli Egyptian
blockade of the border designed to
weaken Islamic militants there both
sides of the border are on high alert
with schools closed bomb shelters open
and troop reinforcements being sent in
on the way here today we saw military
convoys on the road and armored vehicles
massing in fields Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu of Israel cut short
his trip to the u.s. returning here to
Israel in the midst of a tight campaign
for re-election Israelis go to the polls
in just two weeks
gaile Seth Doane thank you reporting
from Israel